each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
Thank You jasmine there will be a lot of
material in here because it's an
overview and I I know exactly that I
will run out of time so well what do I
have 50 minute 45 minutes so I'll try to
pack as much as I can but it's fairly
modular so we can we can it's it it's
more pleasant for me if I know that
you're following along then getting
through the whole material so please
interrupt me if there's something you
don't understand where I'm unclear are
also a quick show of hands how many
biologists okay only card-carrying
computer scientist that is people who do
not you do computer science that does
not touch on biology explicitly okay so
well well okay well we'll we'll proceed
I think I have the slides at that level
is better okay so I think this is an
appropriate quotation because this chap
was running around here in Cambridge and
he pointed out it to understand the
sentence means to understand a language
within the land which means to be master
for technique and these are really the
people who have developed the technique
that I'm giving you an overview off this
is Vincent on ossa the widely known
computer scientist in Edinburgh and you
have met him I'm sure he has been a
frequent visitor here a joke living he's
now at SI no es in Paris at PBS he was
formerly at in my lab sharam frere he is
that anywhere now he also spent two
years in my lab r us harm is currently
in my lab but he will be returning to
seen RS and Eric deeds is a biophysicist
the postdoc my lab who now moved on to
be a professor the University of Kansas
so these
people are really the architects of most
of what I'm saying just to give the the
computer scientist sort of a rough idea
of the domain that I'm dealing with as I
sketch this cartoon we're we're
interested in information processing
inside living cells so what does that
roughly look like well here you have a
cell in the cell is delimited by a
membrane there's a neighboring cell and
then there is some space in between
cells cell has complicated objects
embedded in its membrane these are
proteins or also called receptors their
receptors because in this medium between
the cells there are many different
molecules that get into that medium by
being expelled extruded by other cells
and they attach to these receptors so
these receptors are sensors in a way
that detect the presence of these
molecules when they detect the presence
of these molecules a number of things
happen they combine these receptors bind
to one another and something inside
happens on the portion of these
receptors inside the cell happens that
attracts other components of which there
are many a lot of of processing occurs
and one component modifies another
component which then in turn can modify
yet another component and so on this
activity that spreads throughout the
medium until certain molecules inside
the cell nucleus are being activated and
they start directing the transcription
and then translation of genes and new
components as a result of being produced
the consequences of that is that some of
these components lead to sell to change
its behavior it could start changing its
shape it could start to move it could
start to become a different self
becoming a liver cell a neuron or kidney
cell and some of these components
however that are being regenerated by
the genome are actually come
opponents that already exist inside a
cell and therefore change now the
constitution of this entire sort of
molecular society that processes signals
so that's roughly speaking at the you
know from seven hundred thousand feet
the kind of phenomena I'm particularly
interested in so that's a tiny slice of
molecular cell biology and even the
tiniest slice of biology as a whole
obviously okay so for you the two who
are not familiar with that with the
names what the systems biology really
mean I would like to make a distinction
between systemic biology and systems
biology so systematic biology is a way
of approaching biology that exploits
progress in high-throughput technologies
that enable the collection of massive
datasets in parallel they enable us to
monitor many of these processes I was
talking about before many of these
molecular interactions at the same time
in the cell this is a massively
distributed system and so you can
monitor several of these interactions at
the same time and then follow them
through time longitudinally you can also
sequence massively genomes at a large
scale so this is what i mean by
high-throughput that has given us a
deluge of data of course that in turn
required computer science to come on the
stage to help us organize that those
data sets in nifty libraries and to
navigate that data i'm coming back to
that in a moment but at the same time so
one there is also sort of the need to
put all these data together into a
coherent picture and understand really
how does coherent system behavior arise
from a massively distributed a
collection of individual interacting
processes or molecules in this case so
that's where mathematics comes into play
so systems biologists really brings
emphasizes the need to integrate
experimentation with more formal and
mathematical
approaches to help us understand the
dynamics of these systems and the reason
why of course we want to do this is
twofold one simply practical because we
want to cure disease at the end the end
and for that we need to know how these
systems work this is in some sense a
program as it were we will come back to
that that we don't know exactly whose
source code we don't know quite
precisely but we know it has a bug has a
disease and we want to to fix it so we
need to have approximate models of that
program of the actual program to proceed
in a more reason than rational way than
just by trial and error but then also
intellectually and in the end we want to
have means to think the complexity of a
cell and just then staring at all this
data and for that we need to suitable
levels of abstractions and formalisms
good what has really changed in the past
couple of years is that the kind of data
that has been collected in the past 30
years perhaps has been predominantly
data of a static type gene sequences aug
c or a TA gz so forth or protein
structures so the spatial layout of a
big molecule these are static data types
and they are they almost are born
formally because the sequence is a
sequence there's not much to formalize
their set of XYZ coordinates is already
formalized what has happened more
recently with increasing intensity
partly because of technological
developments is the is an appearance of
facts or factoids of this kind let me
read this because you might not be able
to read at the end but it gives you sort
of a sense of what we're up against as
computer scientists so instead of
getting see gene sequences of instead of
getting protein structures we're getting
increasingly statements in caracal
statements of the kind
a phospholipid taupe of egfr binds
strongly to the SH to PTP domains of
grab to make one pi3 kinase alpha and
weekly to the sh2 domains of grabbed 10
grabbed seven Nick to ship one this is
to me alphabet soup and probably to you
too so these are so what intend to say
these are broad statements the first
seven is a very broad statement it says
that a particular protein a particular
piece of a protein can recognize a lot
of other things okay then there are so
some wood biochemically deeper
statements that add much more detail
like axing one binds a region in the
armadillo repeat of beta-catenin if beta
catenin is unphosphorylated at certain
n-terminal residues it also sounds like
alphabet soup but in essence what it is
saying is that a certain event occurs if
certain conditions on a molecule are our
other case it's important to and we have
gazillions so thousands and thousands of
such facts postdocs spend their entire
entire postdoctoral a period on on
figuring out one or a few of these facts
what is important about all of them is
to realize that are in some sense
fragmentary because each of these facts
is local in the sense that it is a
statement about aspects of a molecule
and aspects of a molecule that are
engaged in interaction but not a
statement about the entire state of the
molecule it's fragmentary its local and
because they're local you can start
thinking of them as little puzzle pieces
that can be plugged together because one
statement might refer to one part of the
molecule and other statement might refer
to another part of the molecule so they
start weaving potentially huge networks
of possible interactions so this is the
kind of of schematic or that that would
attempt to summarize many such
statements what is important to
understand
so what do you see in this diagram what
you see is some each of these nodes is a
protein these nodes are decorated with a
number of other aspects that that
emphasize different sites and domains or
parts of the protein that have to be in
certain states in order for these edges
which symbolize interactions to occur
what is important to understand about
these networks is that unlike road
networks these are not physical networks
these are networks of possibility these
are networks that where you know this
interaction here is possible but it may
only occur if a number of things happen
before so it's not bit such a network if
you were to look inside a cell you would
see such a network like you would see a
wiring diagram when you look at the tip
of a computer no this is just a network
of possible interactions what actually
occurs in a cell is constantly shifting
realization of parts of this network so
this goes therefore without saying that
we we can't spare these pictures and
make a lot of sense of them unless we
begin to think of them dynamically
because it's not just a dynamics on the
network like you would have a traffic
flow on a road network on a fixed
physical road network I mean that's
dynamic too because you need to
understand how the flows off of cars and
so forth interact with one another this
is even worse is this fear sir in a
sense because this is a dynamics are off
the network as well so this to me seems
to to put to the for a kind of a
challenge as to what kinds of models are
appropriate to reason about these these
objects so I will briefly talk about a
scientific challenge I try to
characterize in the next couple of
minutes a scientific challenge or
aspects of a scientific challenge that I
think we're facing knowledge
representation challenge but at the same
time I believe that all of these are
embedded in what I would call a
communication
challenge the problem for us becomes
increasingly to communicate biological
knowledge and I think models in the
future will slightly shift their role
the social role and while we want models
to be of course predicting devices
devices they tell me our if I interfere
with this particular receptor then these
in these are the quantitative
consequences five minutes later ten
minutes later and so on so we would like
altima tlie models will it to be
quantitatively predictive so we can we
can sort of make rational drug design
but for model to become quantitatively
predictive predictive about the kinds of
networks that have the complexity I show
you before it's sort of a long cycle to
get there and so the question is our
models until they get predictive not
useful because they will make wrong
quantitative predictions of course
that's not the case models will become
increasingly as I hope to show you they
will adopt the role of helping us
organize in some sense this this this
deluge of facts about interaction they
are kind of there we can't just list
those facts we need to have the more
dynamic ways of organizing them of
evaluating them even if they're not
quantitatively predictive so models
become vehicles for the communication of
biological knowledge and they should
come kind of open source documents very
much like a program like an open source
program they should be able to be
communicated distributed and developed
by many people simultaneously they need
to be they need to track knowledge facts
in biology unstable tomorrow what you
know tomorrow may not be the same maybe
hopefully more than what you know today
but maybe it will it will it will
disavow what you know today and so facts
change and models need to track those
facts that is a tall order so I believe
in in the end the future of biology it
is not databases as we know them today
that are going to be
critical mission critical in a sense of
databases containing the static facts
but it will with databases of the model
basis we will have large collections of
models that will be used to communicate
store and retrieve biological
information so that's sort of the pitch
overall so what's the scientific
challenge you the scientific talent is
coming tutorial complexity and I can
make this very quick because you all are
familiar with this phenomenon clearly
from your own domain in computer science
by coming toward complexity I mean that
a protein typically has many many sites
at which it can be modified so if it has
three bits at which it can be in two
different states you already have eight
possible modification forms of that
protein the receptors I were talking I
was talking about before have typically
10 or more modification sites so it's
thousand twenty four different states
for a receptor if it dimerizes if it
combines with another receptor then you
already have the dimer has a million
different states and you have just
described a tiny little be a piece of
interaction factors described just one
interaction so complex combination
compounds discriminatory complexity
another thing that is important to a
formula toward complexity to reach
through is concurrency that is it's
enough to have three different site that
you can modify if you can modify only in
if you can modify them only in a
particular order first sight one when
you have modified side one and sigh two
becomes modifiable then side 3 becomes
modified and so on because that would
just cut sort of one particular path
through the space of possible
modifications you need concurrence you
need independence and that independence
is warranted if we are to believe the
data we have today to some degree for
sure so why is this coming to draw a
complexity important well for one let me
just drive home the message even further
if we look at a tiny piece of this map
then this is not a random number this is
really a number that we calculated for a
particular snippet of this of this
diagram
you easily get into astronomic numbers
like 10 to the 19th different molecular
species that you would have to track but
if you were to do this with standard
methods in which you have to our
priority sort of extensional methods in
which you have to operate re specify all
the possible molecular objects that can
occur because you have to write out a
differential equation for example for
each one of them that tallies up the
production and consumption then you're
out of business because you just can't
do that so what people then do is they
they simplify well they're two ways of
approaching the problem one is to say
well and we're not really interested in
in mechanistic aspects we're just we
just want to black box or gray box the
whole system and identify with a
phenomenological input output function
and throw machine learning techniques
edit in order to to see how this box
behaves but we're not opening the box
we're not looking inside that's very
valuable certainly many cases another
possibility is just just to make a hawk
simplification this is what most people
do they say I in all these different
modification forms don't really matter I
collapse all these different
modification forms of a protein into
just one or in to modification forms two
states active or inactive but that's all
done a talk so there is no general a
generality there now the problem here is
while useful in particular instances the
problem that I have with that is that
common Network first of all we may have
to reason at the mechanistic level so we
can't afford only proceeding
phenomenologically because after all if
we develop drugs those drugs act at a
particular molecular interaction level
so we need to be at that level secondly
perhaps more interestingly is that this
combinatorial complexity is a bit with
us now something that is a bit Curtis
seems to me to indicate having a
function of some sort an evolutionary
function it's there for a reason or a
physiological function
what is the function of combinatorial
complexity we can't even ask let alone
answer the question if we have models
that throw out that eliminated
Commendatore complexity to begin with so
this is why why we need to make models
at a more respectful of it to just give
you a slight cartoon of what a small
example of what that coming to our
complexity can do to you this is sort of
the equivalent the molecular equivalent
of what you might call deadlock it's not
quite deadlock it's more something
jamming because in chemistry deadlock
doesn't quite exist since you always
have reversibility so it can retrace
your steps so it's more for jamming so
suppose you have three agents each of
which has two sites agents ABC and they
want to form a triangle they want to
form a complex it is a ring and such
rings are extremely you know but
widespread in the cell ring structures
are you know pores various various the
proteasome a number of molecular
machines contain rings for a lot of
reasons that we can't go into right now
so you want to understand the Assembly
of such rings so suppose now the
interactions are really local for that a
binds to be regardless of whether a is
already bound to see and so on so that
the interaction is strictly strictly a
binder between a and B and C B and C and
pertain only to that interaction that
don't look at the other sites that the
occupancy state of the other side that
is not involved in the interaction so if
you put done a bunch of ABC's into a
virtual beaker and suppose they're all
at the same concentration otherwise
further complexities arise so there's
the same number of A's same number of
these signal of cs so you let them go
what happens is the following this is
time and I have stretched it
logarithmically to make the phenomenon a
bit more clear at the beginning you have
a little lag so then the system starts
what I should say to treasure premise
which I forgot is that every step is
reversible binding and unbinding occur
so binding is reversible except that
when I have
on the triangle I think of the triangle
as an absorbing state the many
thermodynamic reasons why that is the
case so once they've formed a triangle
it stays a triangle so eventually the
whole system diffraction of of
components in the triangular state in
the triangle complex will go to one
everything will end up there eventually
so at the moment just interested in how
it ends up there so at first you know
dimers combined and we'll find another
monomer to recruit into a triangle and
everything and a certain fraction of
triangles will emerge in the system but
then the system hits a plateau on that
plateau it waits for a long time and
then sort of slowly it starts proceeding
to completion now what is this plateau
about well this plateau comes about
because if a if the pairwise
interactions are very strong if the
molecules like one another very much
which I think you would love you assume
to be the case if we want to form
efficiently triangles then you will form
these pairs these dimers a c.b.c a B but
these are all puzzle pieces that can't
interest they can't interact with 1n
email with one another anymore so have
your deadlock because the left hand
doesn't know what the right hand is
doing you ended up with a state of a
sort of everything progressed here along
all possible paths in parallel you know
explore the distributed nature of the
system but then they ended up the system
ends up occupying molecular forms that
suddenly can't contact with one year
with each other anymore because AC
county back with BC so while a can bind
there be it would not be possible
because we we constrain it to be a
triangle that is the B would require
them this this C and this C to clash
because they want to be in the same
space in the same in the same spot so
these two contact with one another for
the same reason these two contact with
one another and you're stuck you're
stuck until one of these dimers
dissociates liberating a monomer which
then can be captured by the other dimer
by a dimer to
the triangle so that's the version of
deadlock it's sort of interesting
because you you you see that there is a
tension in the system you could say well
what if I make my bonds weaker or
stronger if i make my bonds weaker then
i will shorten the period of jamming up
here because my molecules will
dissociate quicker and liberating a
monomers to proceed to the triangle so i
will shorten this period but i will
lengthen this lag phase because if my
interactions are weak it will take a
long time until the first dimers form
okay on the other hand so this is what
you see here these are weak bonds as I
sorry this this is what I what you're
seeing is a plot of the time it takes
for the whole system to get 2.99 all
right so when I week in the bonds it
takes it some point things get worse
because while I'm shorting this I'm
shortening this phase I'm lengthening
this lag time the other hand if I make
bond strong then I shorten the lag here
because the first discovery of the the
first triangles of course and the first
dimers will form very quickly but then I
lengthen my jamming phase because the
association will be slow so again the
the time to completion to full assembly
will increase so there will be some way
an optimum of the bond strength at which
these two trends are our best
compromised and of course needless to
say this is chemistry so it all depends
on the concentration for reasons you
know that would deserve a talk on his
own anyhow the the the reason i mention
this example is just to sensitize you to
the fact that when you have such systems
you you and you and you take into
account all the pathways through which
these these molecules can inter symbol
with one another you you will find you
will find dynamical effects that seem to
me potentially significant but that you
completely miss if you
simplify the system by saying well I'm
not really interested in the you know I
just assume that I have to be monomers
and with a certain rate deform triangles
you know then you use of glossing over a
lot of detail and you're missing this
kind of dynamics that might be quite
important and there's much more to say
about that but for an overview I think
you should do should suffice um
representation knowledge representation
well clearly you know literally these
these facts this fact to it's about
interaction between these proteins these
are these are these these are quotes
from the literature this is how we know
them so this is not this is barely human
readable this is certainly not computer
readable you know try to run a lingua
matic so with this stuff and you will
get your surprises so what we obviously
need to do is somehow as we did
naturally as what's completely obvious
to do with sequences and structures we
need to formalize these empirical
factories so that they become a human
readable but in particular so that we
become computer readable in particular
when we have formalized these kinds of
statements you we can said we can weave
them together into models that are
collections of such statements in
particular those statements then can be
this is something that I said already
before we need to keep in mind the fact
symbology unstable so it's not just
combinatorial state that is a problem in
representing knowledge in this system
but also the fact that knowledge changes
evolves and scattered over many
different laboratories so what we need I
think to to address these two issues is
we need a formal language to represent
these factoids as xik as local rules
founded an abstraction of protein and
anatomy these rules should be executable
account to that in a second much more
concretely we need mathematical sound
and scalable tools to investigate sets
of such rules
which we will call models and we need to
develop a kind of web infrastructure for
not only exhibiting and sharing these
models but also for our creating content
through by enticing a community of
researchers of biochemists to deposit to
formalize the tools and to deposit them
in rural databases so we need a web
infrastructure for the collation of
rules if models are sets of rules then
rules are essentially model elements and
if we had a large database of such
formalized rules making models with 41
become very easy to also our colleagues
at the bench because it's all about sort
of selecting which rules we want to put
together and you already have a model
plus initial conditions etc but you you
you you would not have to start
conceiving of a model or constructing a
model every time from scratch any
particular your model could stay up to
date because if it contains a rule that
tomorrow is being modified because of
new empirical evidence you know like in
your software update you know maybe a
window pops up and says you know your
model has changed there is a new rule
that is available do you want to update
your model you know version 5.63 so so
this would be really useful and there's
a whole other realm here that opens up
which is about you know what does it
mean to publish a model that's that's
another I think very interesting aspect
because publishing models is is not the
same as publishing text models want to
be in some sense applet eyes they want
to be living documents that the reader
can interact with and explore perhaps
even a reviewer so that's that's a whole
other other can so this is just
summarizing again what I said what we
would like to have is formalized Pulos
of such rules of such empirical factoids
we want we want to thank models of
models as being sets of rules we want
models we want to think of models as
evaluating at every point a rule in the
context of other rules may be a small
context of other rules so that we can
understand how it conspires with other
with five other rules that interact with
it
in generating system behavior so this is
the role that models will have not just
becoming predictive eventually but be
long before they are predictive they
become evaluator they become in some
sense debuggers truly debuggers of rule
sets to know what the set of rules is
meaningful whether you didn't make it
whether what you said is what you meant
you need in some sense to put them
together and have them play out with one
another have them play a little concert
and that is what models will do it as a
consequence you will generate hundreds
of models on a particular rule set in
order to evaluate them and I will cause
of this collection of models all of
which pertain to a set of rules that are
specific to our system of interest to a
biologist to a cell cycle for example I
call that an exploratorium so it's to go
away from the natan from the sub-label
model which is to to burden by what we
mean by it in physics this is what i
mean by executable knowledge therefore
so by making these empirical factoids
about interaction formal by providing
arenas in which these formal interaction
statements can interact with one another
and therefore reveal in some sense
directly what the data is about I call
executable knowledge and the dude is in
some sense in horner but also in
distinction to sort of a classic paper
by now I think by by executed by by
jasmine and Tom hen singer who really
should have brought a a concept to the
fore the fact that we did that the whole
idea of programs as models or models as
programs depending on how you want to
see it as distinct from sort of more
more traditional approaches of based on
say differential equations and chemical
kinetics what in fact this whole this
whole sorry for being a bit long-winded
here but I feel so a little bit of
history is perhaps a warranted this
whole idea is not not originated with us
it has been around for quite a while but
it's interesting to see how it came from
computer science to some extent any came
from biology to some extent but it never
came fully to fruition
for very interesting cultural reasons on
the one hand computer scientists took
off the shelf languages for representing
these roles and that's someday what they
got right is of course that when you
think of models as programs you can you
can use sort of 30 years of computer
science or more to brain sort of
concurrency to to bear to brain sort of
model checking to bear to bring a
program verification and so forth to
bear these kinds of techniques that's
what they understood what the biologists
the computational biologists did not
understand but on the other hand they
they they felt were more sort of
interested in in showing that existing
languages could be used to represent
that is information rather than
redesigning a new language that is
perhaps more in tune with how molecular
biologists really think about these
systems that's what the biologists got
right when they tried to approach these
these systems but they have no clue of
the whole formal opportunities that this
would open up and so this led in some
sense to two false starts since but but
interesting starts but in the in the end
starts the little foolish will reach
through I believe to the level of
adoption that we would like to see to
make this to make this take off so now
I'm way way late so give me a I'll just
rush through a little bit what this
formalism consists in what this language
consists in and again mind you i'm
really i'm sort of it's not about all of
biology of knowledge is way too big we
are really interested in the language
that is tightly focused on these
signaling processes okay so it's a it's
a very specific interest we have these
signaling processes are important
because they are underlying cancer there
are underlying is a lot of recalcitrant
diseases there are served the epitome
izing information processing but it's
not the only thing that is happening in
biology of course it's really just a
tiny piece but yeah
crawl walk run this is the world to
structure biologists they have different
representations of their molecules of
course there are different levels of
abstraction that biologists are using
already when they think about their
agents this is this is how we think
about an agent so this is this computer
science where a lot you know off this
it's an agent it has a name it has sites
and these sites will then be defined in
terms of how they can interact with
other sites of other agents through
rules the rules will define those
interactions so what this should just
drive home is the fact that this is a
level of abstraction which we are
informed by everything that is going on
in structural biology but this
representation doesn't expose those
constraints so it hides it and therefore
allows us to focus really on our process
much more so than biologists used to do
in the past yeah I think this is all
okay so what is this language about so I
gave you a sense of what these agents
what the abstraction is the formally
speaking the real the objects of this
language are our graphs a graphs of a
certain kind we call them site crafts
the site graphs because unlike
traditional graphs well like traditional
graphs they do have nodes and links
between nodes but the links are not are
not borne by the nodes themselves but by
sites that are elements of the nodes so
the nodes are sets of sites set not
multisets and these sites bear edges and
the edges symbolize binding
possibilities at the same time a site
might also occur in different states
which we would call internal states that
are meant to to portray phosphorylation
various chemical modifications that
these proteins undergo and this is just
a textual representation of a graph I
don't think there's much need to hear
this audience to to decipher that
textural
it's pretty office is a way of encoding
a graph in a in a string of text so
think of it as a facebook of proteins
here you know who is friend of home now
this is a particular site graft sacra is
coming two flavors this is what we call
a contact map a contact map is a summary
statement of possibilities you may think
of it as a type in fact it is a type
where the characteristic of a contact
map is that each agent that might occur
in my system here occurs exactly once in
that map and that each site might have
more than one edge coming from it
because it's an indication of
possibility it's not an indication of
actuality so actuality is gotten to buy
another kind of site graph which we call
a pattern so pattern is intended to be a
realizable side graph given a contact
map so this pattern has is of that type
because it there's a homomorphism from
here to there that that respects so it
tells me which agent can be in my
pattern in a pattern an agent type can
occur in different instances so there
can be too kind to a's so that's a
concrete thing and every site can have
at most one edge at most one link
because you can't be bound only to one
particular molecule on that channel and
then your your channel is busy so this
is a realizable side craft that respects
a contact map then there is the notion
of it's a pattern because the agents in
this pattern may not exhibit may not
reveal all the sites they have but only
a subset of those sites when they reveal
all the sites they have then there are
sort of essentially a representation of
a molecular species and we call a set of
molecular we call it connected component
in which every site reveals every sorry
every agent reveals all its sights
according to the contact map a molecular
species or a molecule and a set of those
molecules or multi side of those
molecules typically
a mixture okay so these are the concepts
so a rule is there nothing else than
that before that it's like it's a site
graph rewriting system no way but it is
intended so there is a before and
there's an after it is intended to
formalize some of these facts that I
spoke of before so this would say well
if you know you have this kind of
configuration locally then this
volunteer can dissociate this is maybe
an empirical fact if tomorrow someone
comes along is is that but this
dissociation really can only occur if
there is an agency bound to be at a
particular site well then you can modify
this rule so ruled is there will be many
rules because each rule is a kind of
pebble of empirical temporary truce okay
so it's a formalized mechanistic
hypothesis it mentions only that which
is relevant to an interaction and in
this way it deals elegantly with
combinatorial complexity it is
abstracted is informed by structural
constraints by what structural
biologists tell us and biochemists but
it does not expose those constraints it
is just sort of it focuses much more
process well dead in order to decide
that good question order to decide that
I would have to show you the contact map
so the type of this system I'm using the
example of before so because before we
have an aid it is an S I think I used
this one in the rule so this would be a
pattern because this agent a does not
reveal side s which it has in the
contact map okay this is very this is an
exceedingly simple case typically these
agents would have you know pi3 kinase
has perhaps clarity sites and you have
to imagine that these these
representations here you know would be
hyperlinked to also you click on an
agent to go to uniprot and it tells you
know what is the sequence of this agent
you click on the side it goes to 2 2 to
P fam and so forth and tells you what is
the domain etc so so it is it there's
also be bioinformatic information that
you can link to these to these objects
exactly so the idea here here are so
this is the question that you're asking
how does it will apply and where does it
apply at what rate does it apply while
the idea is to have a hella rule you
have a mixture that is a set of now
molecular species so represented so in
the in the mixture every every agent
reveals all its all the sides it has
according to its today to look at the
contact map and the application of a
rule has now too it's a pattern matching
I have to see where this pattern matches
in this mixture it might match in many
different locations but so it matches
for example here and then you you embed
in some sense the left hand side into
the mixture and then you transport the
action along that embedding and you do
so at a rate k so there is each rule has
associated with it an intrinsic rate of
firing for a particular application
instance so let me work this out a
little bit more in detail so here we
have a mixture so suppose this is in
this case it's a single molecule this is
a rule the world we had before and it
fires at rate k2 now notice that there
are two embeddings of this rule of the
left-hand side into the mixture that is
this embedding and there's this
embedding I mean there's a formal
definition of embedding but if the
intuition I think it's clear your
respect agent time you respect the state
of the sites that are being mentioned
etc so therefore the transition in the
mixture so a rule really induces a
reaction or particular transition in the
mixture this transition would occur
twice the rate of the rule because
they're too embeddings at the same time
you know think of this rule here this
will hear also has two embeddings you
know is that disinviting yeah you know
this a or I twist them but the left-hand
side has an autumn morphism so the idea
is that because it has an autumn of ism
you should not distinguish between these
two embeddings that is same physical
event you can't distinguish them so you
should quotient and the transition
occurs really with the rate k 1 even
though it has two embeddings like this
role here so this leads to a definition
of the activity of a rule in a mixture
which is sort of the likelihood the
propensity for a rule to fire and the
activity is given by first of all its
rate constant clearly but then naturally
by the number of embeddings that the
left-hand side of the rule has in the
mixture so there might be many places at
which the pattern matches so that's P I
p sub i said of it's the pattern here
it's the left hand side of the mixture
of a rule I should say of rule I in the
mixture m this is the set of mappings
and the cardinality of that said is the
number of embeddings ok now I have to
divide by the automorphism of the left
hand side but it's not quite that simple
because this is subtle I should divide
and explain density in a second I should
divide by the number of symmetries on
the left hand side that are preserved
across the rule arrow because that are
the seaman toes are the symmetries of
the mechanism we're interested in the
symmetries of the mechanism is this
really subtle because a rule a rule is a
statement about a mechanism so statement
about what you know about a mechanism so
what you say is what you have to mean
for example suppose here i have a this
clearly as a symmetric is a is a
symmetric binding in the sense that this
left-hand side has a symmetry the
non-trivial automorphism and when you
say that all this symmetry is all you
need for a binding event to occur then
you say that the mechanism really can't
distinguish between the various the
various automorphic version CEO of
embeddings and so the number of physical
events is just in half numb of
embeddings this holds even if you're
embedding we're to pick out an
asymmetric reaction because say this guy
embeds into into a piece of your mixture
at which B has some agency hanging off
well this verted is this copy of B does
not have anything hanging off so these
are two different now the symmetries bro
in the mixture but nonetheless the
reaction will proceed this reaction will
proceed with with with a rate that is
the rate of the rule where the number of
embeddings of the left-hand side has
been divided by 2 has been coaching good
because that's what you say you know you
say the mechanism can't you are selling
that the mechanism only sees what you
say on the left-hand side so the
mechanism has to be blind to whatever
else is hanging off the bees even if
that breaks the symmetry that's your
assertion but we have to be very careful
that you know what what you say is
really what you mean in the rule on the
other hand if you assert an asymmetric
unbinding for example this is a
symmetrical there's a symmetry here on
the left-hand side as there is a
symmetry here but the reaction did the
group the action is a symmetric because
the product the symmetry is not
preserved across the rule arrow here the
symmetry of the rule is preserved this
is symmetric and is a symmetric but here
this is symmetric this is not symmetric
but this is symmetric and this is not
symmetric in this case both embeddings
of the left hand side can our physical
events a way of thinking of this is that
clearly there are there essentially two
reaction centers at which something can
happen now this guy can attach here or
they can attach here so in some sense
you could say well I do my quotient
thing by the symmetry but then i have to
multiply by two because really i have
two reaction centers so something to
keep in mind now i'm going way over time
so it's it's a little bit i think i got
out of the way in the beginning of my of
my lecture sort of division i'm now sort
of digging a little bit deeper into how
we're doing things i know you're busy so
we can we can have a question session
now our and or you know i will you can
leave at any time this is not as I I
take not to be a statement about a
out my my digressions here so we will
continue but please you know this is a
don't don't feel obliged anymore go
ahead sure is there any sense in which
the rules can be inconsistent is there
any notion ink ah well you anxious
probably cuz yes no not an experiment an
excellent question that's precisely you
see are the rules should not be
inconsistent when you are making a model
sort of within the model model being
being a thought of as a set of rules the
rules need to be you know whatever you
need my consistent so I will rule i
suppose what I think he's asking what do
you mean by yes I mean I suppose what I
have in mind is that nature itself
presumably is consistent but you you you
tell your rules by sparing exactly none
of your experiments may have it no right
correct correct so right no no I'm I'm
on the page the so let me let me try
differently yes what we might know so
what you find in your lab and what I
find in my lab you know might be might
be very different because we use
different experimental techniques we use
different reagents what have you we we
haven't checked all the controls and so
forth so yes so the empirical facts will
be the factories themselves will be
inconsistent yeah they're huge diatribes
amongst you people in the literature you
know about you no no this is not true
yes this is true but yet cetera so
absolutely those rules should be
formalized and that's the whole point of
having a rule pool a rule pool oh it's
measuring the size of the Grand since I
yeah but yes the the well you know
sometimes what predictability how you
know for for measuring predictable we
have to make models so therefore which
is precisely sort of this debugging idea
where you are claiming that rule the dis
interaction between these two proteins
follows room X I'm claiming it follows
worldwide
but of course what that means can only
be assessed in the context of many other
roles that described further
interactions of these of these molecules
in a slightly larger system in which
they're embedded so now we make models
to assess what are the consequences and
it's extremely useful to have those
models assess the consequences even if
the models themselves are not really
quantitatively predictive because you
know qualitative consequences like oh
this complex cannot possibly assemble if
i use your rule or certainly
intermediates on the way to assembly
would occur if you use my rules but we
have no evidence for those intermediates
so now we can start discussing and
agreeing actually upon you know what we
disagree well so the idea here really
act absolutely is to have a compendium a
corpus of rules that might be
contradictory with one another because
they just reflect what the community
knows and there is no consistency
necessarily across water community knows
neither at any given point in time nor
across time but on the other hand if I
make if I take now a certain set of
rules that are that are there are
potential choices together into a model
and say okay this is now the model that
an interesting that's a little snippet
of a system that I'm interested in I
choose this this this and this in these
rules I put them together and now i have
a little model that choice better be
consistent otherwise you will get you
will get rules that cannot fire or you
will get you know you will you're not
modeling what you were you are intending
to so is that ok so that that's
precisely why we need rules because it's
it's this is what I you know it's
executable knowledge it's jasmine has
pointed out extremely well made a very
cogent case for the importance of
computational models of us programs as
algorithms as a new way of thinking
about what is going on in cells from a
design perspective but from a causal
perspective but at the same time I think
we also need to have to embed this idea
of executable biology of programs
models in in a corpus of model elements
these rules that are represented
critical information and that a
community can can create update and
curate so let me quickly just walk
through was that a question are
inconsistent maybe it might be good to
have some sort of qualifiers that this
particular law in ha would say is that
this pool is Nick and this particular
class in Turkey he says this other move
and all do so if the qualifies that the
secret if the rules are consistent then
you say you don't need the qualifiers
there could be a hierarchy of qualified
that then you say this is basically over
all consistent doesn't need a qualifier
otherwise it will be consisted in a
specific class yeah totally yes
absolutely there is a lot of in a
database of rules there has to be a lot
of annotation annotation with regard to
provenance with regard to conditions you
know you have if you are if you are this
is the Wikipedia of rules and you are
putting in a new a new rule I want to
know what's your evidence why do you
believe this rule is the case and so
here will he be here wit it's not really
uh well it it ultimate you would like to
do now I wish though it was a Wikipedia
because you know i wish i had that level
of adoption and and and it's perfectly
fine because you can have contradictory
and even wrong things in there because
eventually by making models and bye-bye
cross-checking this way you will you
will discover that so yes that's a whole
challenge that i'm certainly not getting
to at all but that was sort of another
part of a talk of how do we create a web
infrastructure that entices people to to
do exactly what you said
machine learning perspective and from
machine learning perspective it might be
there is a problem there in the
framework that if there are certain
qualifiers with the booth how do you
actually merge these qualifiers and come
up with new qualifier is saying now we
have a rule that is consistent over all
under this qualifier under this new body
by point taken yeah so it's it's this is
just the real problem starts now you
know how do we make exactly these kinds
of thing what technology should we bring
to bear to make to watch over a rule
pool and alert us to when things are
inconsistent with one another absolutely
sure our rules sufficiently validated
individually or through models so you
know that you know have these we have
evidence that these three rules we ought
to have these three rules because that
explains this thing that exactly yes or
canard can usually test any given rules
no I rules rules will typically be
tested sort of it's a more a non troppo
logical observation of how to help
people proceed they will be tested in
models that in any context so very often
a rule itself is just a piece of process
and so you typically are interested in a
in a in a little bigger story not the
whole system perhaps it you know right
away but in a little chunk and so you
need to see whether the rule given other
rules that have been proposed before how
he collaborates with these other rules
to bring about the phenomenon that
you're interested in so did the
assessment of an individual rule would
go back to what what what your
colleagues said you know would be about
would eventually have to refer to the
biochemical experiments that people did
and how much you trust that measurement
etc that's sort of an individual rule
but then whether a rule is whether the
that can also be then assessed in terms
of whether the rules behaves correctly
in context of other rules sorry time is
I see from the point of view of program
verification so I'm interested whether
you envisage higher-level rules in which
you could express the hypotheses which
your particular common experiment is
trying to test so that they's wrong you
can knock higher-level experiments using
these verified rules so somebody else's
family for you yes in this case the
rules presumably would be sort of would
be suitably statements expressed in some
suitable logic that asserts something
about the behavior of the system the
same language in which the postulates
express but I
where I'm having difficulty with that is
that the properties I'm usually thinking
of our properties in which time figures
right so for example at before this
event has to happen before another event
can occur for example or this is the
molecular workflow at the event
structure you would say perhaps in
concurrency of how this particular
observable comes about in ninety-five
percent of the cases statements of this
kind so how to represent statements of
the sort in this language where you have
a site graph on the left and the thigh
crab on the right is is is not not in
this is not I don't see that at the
moment but but I take your I take your
your point quite yeah the question is
whether one could what I one could yeah
but so I mean I know that I know that a
number of people here are you know in
jazzman's and in Lucas and in Andrews
when you go to synthetic biology realms
are concerned with precisely a program
verification of model checking in
expressing certain properties of
interest to biologists but now in a in a
in a language the differs are possibly
where in this representation would be a
language to differs from from the the
language in which you described the
microscopic interactions but maybe
Jasmine has a has a representation of
the system itself that is at a different
level and it allows what you're saying
so that's I'm I can't that's the
question to her off probably true
language along those lines when you
specify the rules and they have offices
in the same organism one of the drawer
boxes to get some inconsistency between
the rules because the way they specified
it much more general matter so you could
have formal verification two detectives
and consistency well that's essentially
express the higher-level hypotheses and
low-level interruption mechanism from
the same technology I mean I could I
could see hypothesis of the kind where
you say let's go back to well I'm just
popping up some rule where you are where
where this arrow is really meant with a
star somehow that given if you start out
with a state of this kind then
eventually you know you end up after
sort of many things have happened in in
you eventually enable this action
perhaps that is that that's a way of
thinking about it I mean again I'm not a
computer scientist so I'm trying to sort
of decipher what you have in mind but
typically what I would like in order for
this framework to be powerful the rules
really ought to be as mechanistic as
possible as detailed as possible so i
would like to you know there would be no
point in having a rule that says on this
side lots of damage and on this sides
cell death that lots of damage goes into
cell death well yes but you know I'm the
whole problem the whole point is exactly
to understand how that is is is
happening by microscopic interaction so
the more microscopic these interactions
are the less phenomenal Lord alessan
aggregating they are the better to bet
it is
right this is this all would be possible
to represent in here definitely because
you are might've rules that only start
firing at a later time because the
conditions for the firing is met only at
a later time no no I don't think so how
kind of the whole condition on the
concentration of something else being
easy then well you see that that is what
I would like to avoid in a way that's a
bit ambitious because that conditioning
so did the risk here is in it the name
of the game here is not to make not to
think of modeling as phenomenology
imitation now the point is not to create
a model that that that is that is just
the tracks some data because I can I can
I can make up any model the tracks you
know give me a give me some that's
that's that's overfitting also it if you
have if you think that there's a
mechanism in your system in which you
the application of a rule is dependent
or there's a concentration effect that
content you have to explain that
concentration effect you can't assume it
you can't just put it in and build it
into a kind of aggregate rate law in the
Indy many people use use rape laws in
chemical kinetics that have you know
strong lean on strong nonlinearities
like sigmoid or or or other functions of
that kind when you when you do that you
effectively give them a very powerful
modeling language in which they can
tweak the parameters and make the model
are causally mechanistically wrong model
behave correctly at any time so that's
that's the big problem
we have that we write it Candis Cayne
static so you want really the exercise
here is willing to be to let the data
speak directly by by coating it sort of
in an executable by dressing it up
executable e so that that it made about
interactions start interacting and and
so eventually you might get to higher
levels of description which you
aggregate what were the rules interview
so to switch to a different language
altogether you switch the language of
differential equations and sort of
higher order rate laws but that should
be justified so what I'm arguing with is
that the the models that should be a
process of simplification we all are for
simplification not saying that we need
to have the one inch one inch we we want
to make maps that eventually boil down
to the essence but that's a process that
can only start with first representing
the complex and then in a systematic way
simplifying rather than having models
born simply already because that's on
just only only prejudice I don't know I
di don't want to go too much into a
further but you you can imagine from as
computer scientists can imagine much
better than biologists what you can do
with programs at this point there are
there are lots of you can exhibit the
cause of connections between rules that
is it can draw a network in which each
node is a rule and and an arrow between
one rule and another rule signifies the
fact that a rule made it exists the
state of the world such that the firing
of rule a enables the firing of rule be
in this case it of a causes B or in
which it competed with in which it takes
away instances from rule be in which
case a set of inhibits will be because
any firing of a or any firing of B will
deplete instances for the other so
that's a kind of rule influence map that
you can build a static concept of course
you need simulators
many people here are familiar with sort
of stochastic chemical kinetics from
stochastic calculus Luca for example at
Andrew so there is there are interesting
opportunities here for understanding
causality when you when you look at
these systems what people do when they
simplify it's sort of an interesting
diagram that you've that you often find
interesting diagrams you often find on
whiteboards in laboratories when you
know this is this is really taken
literally from from from such a in this
case a paper pad someone scratched on
when reasoning about a particular
signalling system and that in fact was
the signalling system of the complicated
diagram I showed before so there's an
interesting top-to-bottom layout of this
diagram which in the minds of the
biologists suggests the progression a
kind of a story line things that happen
early are on top and then something
happens and then you sort of progressive
there's a time axis here somehow so if
you're interested in this kind of
observable then something has to happen
before then something NEX that enables
something further and so on these are
sort of the forward this suggests this
layout a partition into two kinds of
arrows the arrows that go from top
towards the bottom so these are forward
steps these are elements of causality of
some kind but then they also have
backward steps these backward steps
can't possibly be elements of causality
because you know what you want to
explain already have to have happened
for those things to become effective
these are sort of more elements of
kinetics they say when you already have
got what you're looking for when your
observable has been discovered in the
system now it turned can feed back and
make more of itself in a dramatic way by
these kind of feedbacks so there's
there's a way of automatically
disentangling these two kinds of things
by precisely applying ideas from event
structures and we're working with glee
and Vince clear across on this where you
can you make a simulation you record all
your events that are introduced by
induced by rules you stop your
simulation Wayne
observable of interest has occurred and
then you reconstruct out of that set of
events those that were necessary in
obtaining in obtaining that observable
you you display them as a dag as a
directed acyclic graph and so now you
have the causal structure that was
necesitas it was responsible for the
occurrence of that observable in that
particular run you do this now many many
times in the hope to accrue statistics
over different such causal structures
and essentially you you get sort of the
pathways what people would call the
pathways at the different ways of
obtaining that observable in a given
system of rules and then you can start
comparing you know which of these
pathways have have you know what
portions are identical what portions
differ and that already allows you to
make predictions when you knock out a
rule because you now modify a protein
you modify a gene so that the particular
rule does not become is ineffective does
that eliminate all the pathways or does
it eliminate only some if it is
occurring in all the pathways then it
should eliminate the observable
altogether and that's a something you
can test at the same time because such a
diagram is a diagram in which each of
the nodes is a rule and it just says you
know everything that has things have can
happen here in any order when they have
happened this can happen and so on
because of this diagram has rules as
nodes and because we have an influence
map that tells us statically already
which rule has a positive or a negative
influence on which other rule we can
start asking does this rule have a
positive influence on a rule up upstream
in this cause all diagram and if so now
we have discovered feedback so this is
you know this is a particular test case
where you have such a causal diagram
which is observable and then you
discover this observable is a rule we
discovered that this rule has a positive
pet in this case as a negative influence
on a rule upstream and so we have
discovered a negative feedback and in
fact this is our reason why this system
oscillates ah i think i think i will i
will just stop here because you know i'm
way over time there are a number of
technical
very interesting issues that we have not
touched upon and I'd be more than happy
to gives it a more technical seminar and
any one of them if if you're so
interested but I hope you've gotten the
sense of part of the story at least what
is really left out from a very practical
point of view which are we were focusing
on right now is precisely the question
that has arisen before it's how to how
to sort of cognitive ergonomics if you
wish you know cognitive design you know
how do you produce a platform a web
infrastructure and associated web
services that that allow special
interest groups in biology that are
interested in this or that signaling
system to to collate rules this whole
process of going from reading literature
whether you read it or whether program
reads you know sometimes in language
with natural language processing ore
mining various databases that exist in
going from the information we have out
there that is mostly verbal when it
comes to interaction to a distillation
of these formal to a formal expression
of this kind or related kind you know
it's not religious about this particular
language that is that's not a trivial
process because it has it involves
certain steps that are there are certain
chunks of information that are
eventually required to design these
rules but how you go to the how're you
how're you how're you how're you distill
those chunks of information is mostly
free form you know you do it differently
than I do it you might read the papers
in a different sequence than i do then i
read them so you might come up with how
to organize that is I think a challenge
but a challenge we have to we have to
meet because the opportunities are just
intellectually and and in some sense
practically are just sheer enormous so
you know I leave you with that thought
if you have any ideas of how to do that
if you want to compare notes
I'm available time so thank you for for
your patience and I really apologize
driving mean so inconsiderate but you
have been staying I told you